- Hey everybody welcome
to the podcast.
My guest today is Karamo Brown.
You know Karamo as
the culture expert
on the hit Netflix
show Queer Eye.
What a beautiful, delightful
man and soul he is.
So hit that subscribe button,
and without further ado,
please enjoy our conversation.
(upbeat music)
Well, welcome to my home.
I'm so delighted
to have you here.
It's been a little bit in
the making to get you here,
but I'm so excited, everybody.
I mean, I've been doing
this for eight years,
I've never seen my
family more excited
to meet (indistinct).
(laughing)
They all turnout
here to welcome you.
- I appreciate that.
- And you asked, you asked
a minute ago, like why?
I thought we were going to
do that in the black box room
where we have been recording.
Historically, we've always
done the podcast here.
We have another room on the
other side, but when COVID hit
we moved it out to a neutral
space just for safety reasons.
But with you, it's like
I can't record a
podcast with Karamo,
like he has to come.
So, that's the whole thing.
This is what you do.
- I appreciate it.
Your house gorgeous.
- I appreciate that.
- And we find out
we're neighbors.
- Yeah, I can't believe
that, that's a mindblower
and we've got the doors open
and I've never sat so far away
from a podcast before.
So we've undertaken
safety protocols
to make sure we're safe.
I know you've been tested
a lot as have I so,
we can kind of breathe,
relax, and enjoy,
each other's company man.
You reached out to
me, which blew my mind
because I had mentioned in
a podcast with my buddy Adam
that our whole family had
been enjoying Queer Eye
and I was late to the party.
Like my relationship
with Queer Eye was
the original cast in series.
So, the new one
launched in 2018, right?
- Yeah.
- Spent five seasons.
- The joke is whenever there's
a Republican in office,
Queer Eye needs
to come back, so.
- Ratings go up.
And I had never watched,
your version, the new
iteration of the show
until the beginning
of the pandemic.
And we just latched
onto it as a family.
And it's like the one show
that we can all enjoy.
Like if you met my whole family,
lots of ages and you
know, going on here,
and we would just look
forward to it every night.
We went through all
five seasons and
it was just
absolutely delightful.
And I was like, I can't believe,
I didn't know about this show.
And I was raving about
it on the podcast.
And I couldn't believe it
when you reached out to me
because of course I'd
wanna talk to you.
You're my guy.
- Well the love is
mutual obviously.
Me reaching out to you was
cause I was like super fan.
I just love the way
you have conversations,
the way you engage your guests.
And you know, I always,
even though I'm on this show
I don't have this
Hollywood mentality yet.
And I hope to never get
that Hollywood mentality.
So I'm always like,
hey, you really cool.
Do you think I'm cool too?
I feel like a seventh
grader all the time.
- I do too, it's funny.
And I'll never forget Jaya,
our youngest who you met,
who's a huge fan
of you in the show.
I was like Jaya,
Karamo DMed to me.
He wants to come on the show
and just looked at me confused.
She's like, what could
he possibly wanna talk
to you about?
(Karamo laughs)
- Jaya, your dad is cool.
Your dad is really cool.
- Yeah, you're doing
me a solid in the eyes
of my daughter by being here.
- Awesome, is the one
that helped direct me?
- No, that was Mathis.
Jaya is the one with the
reddish (indistinct),
yeah, she's 13.
Anyway, happy to be
here today with you.
- [Karamo] Same.
- And you know, I wanna
kind of unpack the show
and your personal story,
but in thinking about how
to approach this with you,
I was thinking about like what
makes Queer Eyes so magical?
And I think what it
is in my mind at least
and I'm interested
in what you think,
to me it's like this
antidote to our,
very kind of acrimonious
divided culture at the moment
because it's so infused with
hope and love and compassion
and understanding, it's
devoid of all the judgment.
That seems to be the
touchstone of all other forms
of media that are popular or
that we're consuming right now.
And I can only presume that
that was very intentional
from the get-go.
- Yeah, it was.
I have told this
once before that,
one of the reasons I believe
that the five of us got the job
is because when they got
down to the final casting
where they brought
like 60 to 70 guys
into like do chemistry
tests, to see which five.
So people were
different categories
and they just start
putting you together.
One of the things where
within the first hour,
myself, Bobby and Tan connected
then it was Antony within
an hour and a half.
And then Jonathan within
two hours was because
they would take you in this room
and they would ask you questions
and people will come out and
say, what did they ask you?
And we were the only five
that were willing to tell
what was being
asked in the room.
Other people were,
you know, were like
I'm not telling you,
you're my competition.
But we just didn't feel like,
we were thinking to ourselves.
Well, I was personally and
now talking to the guys
and I still get these
little goosebumps.
We were thinking,
well, if the show is
to make people better,
the best people should get it
but you should be wanting
to make people better.
And if you can't
do it in a casting,
then how are you authentically
gonna do it out here because
like every round
someone would get cut
and you never know
who's gonna be.
So if I'm getting cut and I
could have maybe helped you
a little bit along your
way, then you know, why not?
And the casting director
said it was so apparent
because they were
listening in on everything
that we would come out
and we would be like,
yeah, here's what happened.
Or here's some advice for you.
Here's how you could do it.
And, I think that was part
of on top of the chemistry,
on top of all of us being
great at what we do.
I think it was them seeing like
these people actually are living
this idea of not dividing,
not judging, not hurting others.
Like they really just wanna help
cause they're doing
it in the casting.
- The universe is abundant
as opposed to a zero
sum game situation.
- [Karamo] Completely.
- And the casting was like a
year and a half for this show.
Some crazy long period
of time, may seem--
- Yeah for some,
my casting was only two weeks.
So I had actually,
Jonathan had been in
for a year and a half.
I think Tan had been in
I came in two weeks before
they were doing
that chemistry test.
I found out about the
show through watching
Watch What Happens
Live with Andy Cohen.
Carson Kressley who was in
the original cast was on.
And he was saying they
were rebooting the show.
And I called my agent and my
agent got on this told me,
no, you already have a job.
Cause I was filming
a show for MTV,
said we're not gonna
put you up for it.
And I got off that
phone and I was like,
I'm not accepting this now.
This is not a no
that I'm okay with.
And I called him
back and kept saying
we need to keep working.
We need to figure this out.
And not in a, you know what,
egotistical or mean way.
It was just like sometimes
you have to follow
and trust your instincts.
And I think that
the universe will,
or people in your circles
will sometimes make you doubt
what you know to be true.
And I knew that, whether
I got the show or not
I needed to be exposed
to this opportunity
and to these people.
And I kept saying, you got
to, you got to, for a week.
And finally my agent found
someone who he knew in casting
from a long time ago.
And they were like, we'll
give him 10 minutes on,
this is before Zoom,
almost said Zoom, Skype.
And were like, we can Skype him
and see if he's even worthy
to come to the chemistry test.
- Wow, cause it had already
been going on for so long,
you came late into the game.
- Yeah, and they said
after the 10 minutes,
they were like,
we'll bring you in.
- [Rich] Wow.
- And I asked, why was it?
And they were like, well,
you were the first
person who talked about
the culture category from
a mental health standpoint.
Everyone else was artists,
musicians, you
know, playwrights.
You're the first one that
said mental health need to be
the component of the
show that was missing.
And they were like, we
were interested and curious
of what you wanna do with it.
And obviously it worked.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It worked.
- That term culture though is
a legacy of the original show.
And I think I said
in the other podcast,
I was like, I'm confused.
Like, cause it's not like,
what you do is so much broader,
culture just seems a misnomer
to characterize your function
on the program.
- Yeah, I agree with you.
And it was a struggle for me
season one, because people,
especially season one,
people would be like,
we don't know what he does
because the show is
being established.
So it was like, he's
having long conversations.
What is his thing?
Especially when you have people
who do physical attributes
like you see a home,
you see someone's hair,
you see what's on their
plate, you see their fashion,
you know having a conversation.
People were like,
I don't get it.
And when you don't have a title
that clearly helps
people understand
that he's working on the
mental and emotional state,
it was hard.
But I had to release
my ego and say,
if people don't
get what I'm doing,
as long as the
person we're helping,
that's all that matters.
And people finally
figured it out.
They're like, oh, he's the guy.
And I think it's
because of the crying,
like every time I'd
get on a screen,
the person will start crying.
They're like, okay, we can,
oh, we understand
what's going on here.
Yeah, and so.
- Well, I'm crying,
my family's crying.
We're all crying.
You know, I was like, oh my God,
who knew this was gonna be
such an emotional journey
week in, week out.
Like you just crush it.
Like there's no, like missteps.
Was there ever an episode
where you spent a week
with somebody and you're
like, this isn't working.
- Yeah, twice.
I always joke to people.
If you go back and
watch the episodes,
if Jonathan doesn't twirl
up the room, you can tell,
cause he's probably the one
that's gonna always share
through his body language
what we're all
feeling collectively.
If he doesn't twirl
a lot of room,
it most likely means that
we were just ready to go.
(both laugh)
- So you've been
like two days in
and just pull up the stakes
and like, we're done with this.
It's not happening.
- Yeah, there's two people
for sure that I know.
And it pisses me off, if I
can be very honest with you.
Like when I think back
about those people.
So I keep up with all the
individuals we've ever helped,
especially with my role of...
- Yeah, that was a big
question that I had.
- Yeah, I think it's important.
I don't think it's
healthy to open people up
and not give them an
opportunity to still do,
to speak to you,
to talk about whatever
you talk to them about,
give them that
sort of aftercare.
And the show does provide
aftercare as well.
So, it's not all on me.
- Oh, that's good to know.
- Yeah, so we make sure
that they're good, but
there are some individuals that,
the two that I'm thinking of
that made me so mad because
we have so many
people who will apply
and who would love
this opportunity.
And when you get
someone who slipped
through the cracks somehow,
and then comes here
and doesn't take full advantage
of five experts in their field,
take advantage of a
crew of 70 people,
take advantage of
all this exposure
that you could get afterwards.
And they're just
like, eh, I don't,
it just upsets me.
And like, you know,
a few things really,
really upset me
but that's one of the one.
- Yeah, well, I mean,
they're not ready.
I mean, that's a fear
response, isn't it?
- Oh, completely
a fear response.
But you know what the show is.
- Who doesn't want
Bobby to come in
and like completely
redo their house like
by snapping his fingers.
- Well, that's the thing.
And what we realized and,
our casting department is great.
They've started to
get savvy on that.
Is it just because they want
the free house makeover.
And I think that's the key
where these two individuals
were like, yeah,
come and do my house.
And they played the game
with the other categories.
But you know, now we're,
that's like the last thing
that they find out
that they might get.
- Well, all of you
guys could experts
in your respective
fields, but the chemistry
that you guys have together
is clearly the gold.
I mean it's unbelievable the
way that you guys gel together.
So taking it back to
that casting experience,
was the casting director,
like, okay, you go in
and you do your audition
and then you come out and
then they're watching like
how everybody's interacting
with each other,
cause that's key.
Like if you don't have that
the show is not gonna work.
- Yeah, they were watching
both inside the room
and outside of the room to see.
And like I said, it took
us an hour and a half
on the first day for the
five of us to come together.
And the ironic part is,
the five of us didn't know
if we were competing
against each other
if we were in the
same category now.
So we were hanging and
didn't know because it wasn't
until the second day that
they gave everyone stickers,
that said, like your
culture, your food.
So I didn't know what
category anyone could be in.
And they didn't know
what category I was in.
And I think that helped
that we organically
found each other.
Awesomely we're not
in the same category.
We were also diverse.
And it was like, sort of like,
I think things just
work out the way
that they need to because.
And then once we
got into the room,
they would bring other
people in and you would,
eventually it just was
the five of us in there.
And then they had this other,
another five five squad who was,
I guess there are other choice
which were all
phenomenal people.
But I still remember on
that last night, I was like,
they were like,
well, we'll tell which one of
you groups are gonna make it.
I looked at the other
group and I was like,
you are great, but I'm sorry,
you're not getting this.
I was like, sorry.
You're not getting this at all.
Yeah, yeah.
I know, I still (indistinct).
- It's gotta be a
little disorienting
with the success
of the show though.
I mean, you guys just
got Emmy nomination,
it's like a cultural phenomenon.
- Yeah, it's humbling.
- But you've been
on TV for a while
doing all kinds
of different stuff
but nothing at this scale.
- No, no, no, yeah.
After college, I
did The Real World
and then stopped doing
anything because,
went on my journey of sobriety
and take care of my kids
and then came back
out here to establish
a real career in television.
So for four years I was
doing like digital shows
for the Oprah Winfrey network.
I worked at HuffPost Live
and things of that nature.
And so this was my
real first job ever,
even though those were all jobs.
And it is overwhelming and
it's humbling because again,
I promise you if
you meet any of us,
none of us have gotten
that celebrity bug.
You know, like you meet
people in this town
and you're just like,
you're like, come on now.
Like, you're still human being.
I know how you
put on your pants.
I know how you brush your teeth.
Like the, well let's
treat each other as if
we're all the same.
Just because we have a
little bit more money
or you have a little
bit more success,
we have to remember those
things are fleeting.
And the five of
us remember that.
And so, luckily we have each
other to ground each other
which is nice.
- That's beautiful.
I mean, that's just walking
the talk of the show though.
You know what I mean?
- We try.
- Yeah, well, you've
done the work.
I mean your background
is pretty extraordinary
and the obstacles that you've
had to face and overcome
to get to this place.
So let's like take it
back there for a minute.
- Sure.
- Growing up in the South.
- Yeah, growing in the
South, immigrant parents.
- Texas and Florida, right?
- Texas and Florida, my
parents are Jamaican and Cuban.
So, you know,
being a little gay black
boy to immigrant parents,
growing up in Texas and
Florida had its moments,
let's say the least.
You could feel, you could see,
the racism, the homophobia.
And I was just the direct target
because one of the things
that I always say to my father
would always, he had this
map like old school map,
like a MapQuest store ways.
And he would go through it
and he would basically red
line the school districts
and see what apartment
complex we could live in
so that we could go to the
school that was best funded.
And unfortunately, the way
our system is worked out
mostly the best
funded schools are
in predominantly
white neighborhoods.
And so I was always that
one apartment complex
that was right on the outskirt
of these 1 million, 2
million, $3 million homes.
And then I walked into
the school and I'm one of
three African-Americans or
one of five children of color.
One of two kids who
had immigrant parents.
I was the only one in
high school that had,
decided to let people into
their life about my sexuality.
So it caused this extreme
conflict consistently.
It was like my existence
was always in conflict
with where I was.
And as a child, you
don't understand why
your life is conflict
and why you are the
reason for conflict.
And as I got older,
I started to realize that
this was the biggest blessing,
all these different
identities and managing them
because now I use
those conflicts
as tools to help other
people navigate their own.
I use those conflicts
to be more empathetic,
to like understand where
people are coming from
versus it could have made the
opposite of me being like...
- Victim.
- Yeah, F the world.
- Well, your dad's
intention feels like
it came from a good place.
Like he's trying to
find the best school--
- Of course, yeah, I know
that was a great place.
- It's like a by-product of that
is everything that you had
to go through and suffer.
- Yeah, yeah.
And, you know as dads,
I appreciate it.
So I don't talk about
that in a bad thing.
The one thing I do talk about
and the reason I bring that
story up specifically is
because that's still
the problem today.
We have an underfunded
education system
and it only gets worse
as you get into low
income neighborhoods.
And I think sometimes we have
to really take a look and say
what is wrong with
us as a society
when kids are not our priority,
that's the biggest thing.
Like when we saw with
the gun violence,
cause you know that
was my high school,
Marjory Stoneman Douglas,
where you know, the
high school students.
Yeah, Parkland.
I always think if
those kids dying
can't get us to get some
comprehensive gun legislation.
If kids not being able to
eat in school and passing out
can't get us to
start feeding kids.
If like, who are we as a society
if we won't even take
care of our children?
Like, and that's one of the
thing that blows my mind.
And I'm sure as you, as
well as a parent, it's like
there's no way one of your
kid's friends will come in here
and say I'm hungry or I
don't have a book to read
and you'd be like,
sorry, go home.
You would feed them
and give them a book.
And you know, it
just blows my mind.
- Yeah, was your high school
the same high schools.
I mean part, was it a
different high school?
- No, the same high school,
Marjory Stoneman Douglas.
Yeah, that was my high school.
- You went back and visited.
Yeah, after this happened.
- Yeah, I did.
And I started working
with the school
cause a lot of the kids
were going through trauma
and so they called on alumni.
But the thing for me
about that incident,
which a lot of people don't
know is that one of the teachers
he was protecting the
students and he got killed
was actually my high school,
we went to high school together.
We graduated the same time.
And so when I watched
it on the news,
not only was I like feeling
this anxiety of being a father
with my kids going to
school, also watching
my high school be shot
up and the kids and,
seeing their fear and
hiding home there.
But then a day
later to see someone
I actually graduated from.
And I remember when he
sent the Facebook message
to say he was going
back there to teach,
and now dead.
Like, it made me feel
like I was 16 again
because I'm like,
ah, too close to home.
Like, you know.
- Wow.
And with conflicting
emotions probably
about that time in your
life and that experience.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so.
- When did, you know the
sexual identity aspect
of growing up,
come to be a thing.
I mean, you sort of came to
terms with that around 16 or so?
- 15.
It came across very quickly.
I mean, you know, Zack
Morris on Saved by the Bell,
helped that a lot.
I kind of figured
it out very quickly.
Like, oh, I like boys.
And so I think the journey
to accepting love myself
was a difficult one
because my father was
Jamaican, is Jamaican
and the music and the
culture previously
they've gotten a lot better,
subscribed to a lot
of homophobic ways.
And so there was a song
called Boom Bye Bye
by an artist called Buju Banton.
And the song went like this,
boom bye bye (speaking
in foreign language),
which means homosexuals head.
You're not supposed to
promote these nasty men.
You have to kill them dead.
And that song would be playing
at family functions
consistently.
And it had a great beat and
people are dancing to it.
And the whole song is
about killing any gay men
onsite that are,
and this was like
number one on the radio,
and number like 10 on the
radio here in the States.
So I want you to
imagine a popular song
that's promoting killing gay men
and I'm five, seven, eight,
nine, and the songs are playing.
And so it made me feel
fearful for my own life.
It made me feel,
unsure about the love that
my parents really have,
because if you could
sing that song,
unknowing that I was gay,
then do you really love me?
Once I say this to you, are
you gonna try to kill me?
Those are the types of
things you play in your head.
- That's horrible man.
- Yeah, you know.
But I think about that,
we still haven't gotten to
a place with some rap pop,
some rock lyrics,
they still promote this.
And people don't realize that,
you saying no homo has
a connotation to someone
who could be, who identifies
by the LGBTQ community
and who was having
self-esteem issues.
And every time you say no homo,
how does that affect
their self-esteem?
Because you're saying
that if I do something
no homo means it's bad.
So like, I'm not bad.
That's bad.
I'm not bad.
And so I think it's just
about being clear about
what are you subscribing to
and like really
watching your language,
because language has power of
how it affects people's mood,
self-esteem, growth, everything.
- Yeah, wow.
That's heavy and,
where are you at with
your dad these days?
- We have a like,
you're good, I'm good.
Like, hey, you know,
you stay there.
The problem is that even,
my father is 70 now,
we had many years that
we didn't talk at all.
But then like, as I got
older I did try to reach out
and he just could not.
He just still to this
day cannot reconcile
his religion with his
relationship with his son.
And I think that's a problem.
When you can't
reconcile your religion
with your relationships,
then there's an issue there.
Because for me, the
religion is teaching you
to have healthy
relationships through love.
But somehow, the
Bible is then teaching
a different version of
what could be coming out
of other people's now,
there was supposed to be.
And so he's just never
been able to reconcile it.
And so I had to come to the
place and say, you know what
since you can't
reconcile that decision
I have to make a
decision for myself.
I have to love me
more than I love you.
I have to trust me
more than I trust you.
I have to be there for
myself more than you
could ever be there for me.
And then that was sort
of the the first step
in taking away the
pressure of feeling like
I have to have this
relationship with my father
just because he has
the title father.
- Right, right.
That's the thing.
I mean, I feel like most people
have some version of issues
with their parents,
and it's the rare case that
somebody can really process it
and heal from it and get to
the other side of it where
they're not carrying
around this burdensome,
resentment and anger,
constantly looking in
the rear view mirror
like analyzing what
that experience was
like that takes a lot of work
and most people just
compartmentalize it and move on.
- Well, one of the things
that I used to tell myself
and I try to help,
especially when I worked
in social services,
I would tell kids
as sort of something
that's springboard them to a
happier healthier life is that
whatever situation happened,
didn't happen to you,
it happened for you.
And I think that
language right there,
it didn't happen to
me, it happened for me.
It's such a beautiful way of
helping you to understand that,
yes, you had an experience
that was traumatic
but what could you learn
from this experience?
How can you grow?
How can you be healthier?
How can you be the best
version of yourself?
How can you start to heal?
Because when you say
it happened to me
you live in this place of
letting the trauma overtake you.
It's always like,
this happened to me.
I wasn't good enough.
I wasn't strong
enough to handle this.
What did I do to
allow this to happen?
Why wasn't I loved enough?
You start to do all these whys,
instead of saying
this happened for me
so that I could understand
that I could be stronger,
that I could love myself.
And so when I think
about the relationship
that I have with my
father and uncles
who couldn't reconcile
their religion
with their relationship with
me because of my sexuality,
I say, you know what
that happened for me
so that I could be
here today, stronger,
loving myself more
versus it happened to me.
- Yeah.
It's easier to be on
the other side of it
though and look at it that
way, like intellectually.
Yeah, of course.
But when you're in it,
when you're mired in it,
it's very hard to like
see your way through
and to really grab onto that.
- Oh, 100%.
That's why I think that they
should teach meditation.
I think one of the
things that I think
that they should have
not taken out of school
was quiet time.
I think, you know,
they got it right
in kindergarten.
In pre-K, when you
have quiet time
because what would
happen is that
it would allow all the kids
to settle their nerves,
to take a moment to
reflect, to recharge.
And I think we get into this
as a culture, as a society.
It's like, you have
to go, go, go, go, go.
And you don't look at
social media, everything
and people don't slow down.
And I think that if
we had an opportunity
for people to take a step back,
especially in traumatic moments,
through an organized,
through school where
they're like, let's stop,
so you can process
what's going on.
I think it would allow
people to then get
to that intellectual
place at a younger age
versus being older, because
no one allowed me to stop.
So I felt like I had
to continue to run.
I felt like I continued
to have to fight
because of the fact that I
was like, if I stop, they win.
When actually, if I
would've stopped sooner
I would have healed
quicker, I would've won.
Because I would have
more understanding that
this is your ship,
this is not my ship,
you know what I mean?
So that's, I talk about
education a lot and kids.
- Well, I mean,
there's so many things,
with both parents.
I mean, there's so many things
that I wish we could change
about the educational
system and right now.
Yeah, of course, thanks.
In the midst of this pandemic
when everyone's at home
and on Zoom, I mean,
prior to this, the incidents
of mental health issues
among teens was extraordinary.
Now it's spiking like crazy
depression, anxiety, stress,
all the like, and there's no
kind of institutional
programming around well being
in the educational system,
whether it's private or public.
Like, my great desire, this,
and I'll be,
projecting my own experience.
But, I want my
children, my daughters
to emerge from their
educations feeling,
a sense of empowerment
and self-esteem
and agency over their lives
and a feeling of capability
that they can manage the world.
Like all of these life skills,
there's so much more
important than memorization or
whatever being tested this week.
- I agree.
- We just completely
turn a blind eye
to this fundamental aspect of,
how to live successfully
and be happy
and productive and fulfilled.
- Yeah, and I think that's
part of the reason why,
as American culture, like we
are not number one anymore.
You know what I mean?
Because we are missing such
a key fundamental
piece here like,
people need education, they
do need the memorization,
they need to go those things.
But that's 25% of what has
made me successful in my life.
You know, like the skills
I learned in school,
obviously, yes, I have them
but it's through the
life experiences.
And it's through,
like you just said
having agency over myself
and over my emotions
and being able to
communicate and being able
to take care of my mental health
and being able to
do all these things
that schools don't talk
about, the life skills.
It's like the fulfillment you
get from balancing a checkbook
or knowing your credit's good.
Like, people just need
that like little things.
I think that we've
missed the boat on that.
And I think that we need
to get back to a place
where we start to evaluate
how we really grooming our
generations to succeed.
And right now I think
we're grooming them
not in the best way.
Like they, luckily some of
our kids have us at home
where we're like, no, we
want you to be empowered.
We want you to use your voice.
We want you to understand
how the world really works,
but there's other
kids who feel like
if I don't get an A
here, then I'm not worthy
and that's not, I don't
think that's healthy.
- Yeah, I don't think so either.
And you know, I'm just,
as you're talking
I'm thinking about,
the many times
throughout the show,
there's always the situation
where you go on a walk
or you're driving in a car with,
this week's person
and the heart to heart
it's coming, you know coming.
And you have this
unbelievable facility
for not just being able
to kind of extract out
the most important aspects
of what's dysfunctional
about this person and how to
help them see their way forward
but an extraordinary
ability to communicate it
in a very clear
and digestible way.
Like it's very concise
and it's done with compassion
and without judgment.
So the is able to really
kind of take it in.
And I would imagine for
a lot of people who,
the millions of people that
are tuning into this show
like most of them maybe have
never had any experience
with therapy or mental health.
Like you're their
first introduction to
some of these ideas
that have been certainly
life-changing in your own life
and for all the
people that you touch.
- Yeah it is.
And it's pretty amazing to think
that I am their
first introduction.
And I take that
responsibility very serious.
And also the rest of the guys,
we all take that responsibility
because even though
that's my main focus.
One of the things I do love
about the rest of the cast,
especially Jonathan, he and I
connect deep on this is that
we both are very much
about like mental health
and like the awareness.
And we do understand that
there's a lot of people
who are in countries
because we're,
you know, it's Netflix.
So we're global now.
Like I've traveled now.
Last year, my family we were
blessed enough to go to Bali
for two weeks.
And we're in this
jungle and this kid,
and his mom went up and
they're like Queer Eye,
and I'm like, this is a amazing.
Like you just can't,
you know what I mean?
And they're just asking for
a hug and I'm thinking like
I'm in the middle of
a Bali in the jungle.
And this kid knows me
because of this show.
And what he knows about me is
that you're supposed to
check in with yourself.
You're supposed to love
yourself and you're supposed to.
And I was like, that
just blew my mind.
But so I take the
responsibility.
It's very important to me.
I love it because I
hopefully we're giving people
and hopefully I'm giving people
ways of really checking in
with themselves that are
not so much over their head.
I think a lot of
times these concepts
can go over people's heads.
So I always try to
like break it down.
Not because I think
people need things
to be dumbed down to them, but
sometimes in our busy lives
you just need something
that you're like,
oh, I can grab this.
- The one thing that I can do.
- Yeah, I can do this.
You know, like not
something that's so big
that you're like, I can't,
it's gonna consume me.
Just do this one thing.
Here you go.
Let's start with this.
- Well, as they say in the
secret halls of recovery
you can't transmit something
you haven't got, right?
- Amen.
- And that goes back to what
you were saying earlier about,
is this happening to you
or is it happening for you?
Like when you can
imbue that idea
that it's happening for you
and avail yourself of
the opportunity to,
really like bear hug it and
use it as a modality to heal
as opposed to become a victim,
you can emerge
stronger from that.
And you know, you've only
shared a few of the many things
that you've had to do.
I mean, you had, like, you
found out you had a son
when you were in
your early twenties.
Almost your age.
- And it is funny.
We were in the car
literally three days ago.
And he was like, just
sitting there randomly.
He was like, when
you're 65, I'll be 50.
And I was like, yeah.
And he was like, no one's
gonna think you're my dad.
And I was like, I
mean, it happens now,
people think we're brothers,
you know what I mean?
But yeah, the one
girl that I had,
she was my best friend.
We lost our virginity
to each other.
It was also the catalyst for
me to start letting people
into my life in regards
to my sexuality.
It was like, okay,
I know this is not for me.
And so it was one of those
things where I was like,
yeah, I guess this is it.
And then she moved
away, you know, I'm 40.
And so people who are
younger might not get this
but if you didn't have someone's
address or homeless phone.
- That was it.
And so once she
moved, it was done.
And then years later,
there's that stack of papers
on my doorstep for (indistinct).
- You didn't know
that she got pregnant.
She moved away.
- She moved away.
She got pregnant in,
if I do the math back,
I guess it was like May
and then we were out
of school by June.
So we went on summer break,
and then she moved
during summer break.
So that was,
yeah, that was it.
- So your son was 10 when
you were informed, right?
- Yeah, 10 years old.
And I was like,
what in the world?
And at this point I
had been going through,
I mean, it was like
party LA central.
I just got off the real world.
I'm done with college,
the real world back
then, it was like,
if you're on reality television.
I don't know if it's same now,
but back then, it was like
you would do these club tours
and you would go to tours
and they would pay
you $20,000 to party
when I would have
partied for free.
And so it's like, I'm
23 partying, doing
all these things.
They're giving you drugs.
They're just taking care of you.
And I just got really
unhealthy, really depressed.
And it was because I
didn't really focus
on the trauma from my past.
I wasn't looking at
what was making me feel
like this behavior was okay.
Why was it okay for
me to destroy myself?
Why was it okay, why was
I so okay with hurting me?
And so as my son, I
found the paperwork.
It was at the same time when
I was finally starting to heal
and saying, you know
what enough is enough.
I don't wanna hurt me anymore.
The world does
enough of hurting me.
I don't wanna hurt me anymore.
And so I started to heal,
get help for my addictions.
And then now it
was like this kid
and it was the perfect thing.
I tell people all the
time, he saved my life
because I don't know
what would have happened
if I would've found out
at 16 that I was a father.
I don't know if I'd be sitting
here right now, I don't know.
And I don't like to
speculate, but I do know that
at that moment I needed
something ground,
life-changing to step in and
like really make me commit
to who I wanted to be and
to stop hurting myself.
- Yeah, the universe delivered.
- Delivered, right on my doors.
- Timing was perfect.
- Yeah, on my doorstep.
And so I moved back to
Texas to get custody of him.
It was, you know, crazy moment.
I then got custody of
his little brother,
same mother, different fathers
because he was having some
troubles with the state.
And because of my,
work in social
services, I was like,
I can take him for temporary.
And temporary turned into,
you know, he's 20 now.
He (indistinct) time.
And so it, but it helped
me understand like
oh, you can be better knowing
it for yourself but for them.
- So you're like 26, 27
and you're like I'm adopting.
- 27.
- I got a son and I'm
adopting this other kid.
And now I'm a single dad of two,
leaving LA and my fancy
TV real-world life
(indistinct) back to Texas.
- It wasn't that fancy.
It wasn't that fancy.
- It's fancy for most
people, 20 grand to go party.
That sounds like pretty good.
- And this is the funny part.
I would get 20
down and go party.
And then maybe three
days later, I'd be like,
how's my phone bill
getting turned off.
And I was realizing
because you're 23
and you don't know
how to manage $20,000.
So it was like, hey,
everybody get into,
you know we're all,
I'm buying a trip.
We're all going.
And then, oh, you
want those shoes?
Sure, get those shoes,
we're all doing it.
And then you're like, oh,
because I didn't know.
You know so.
- So did you just
like get struck sober
or did you go to like
12 step or treatment,
how did you do that?
- I did not.
I did it on my own,
which I regret.
I wish that I would've
had someone to guide me
but my family, especially
in African-American cultures
and immigrant cultures,
therapy, addiction recovery
is not something that
they're educated on.
And a lot of times and I'm
not trying to generalize,
but from my experience,
the community that was in
of African-American
people or immigrants
just did not know about therapy,
did not know about rehab,
didn't have the money
or the resources.
And so it was sort of
like this thing of like,
pray on it, you know
like, or just stop.
- But you study this
stuff in college, right?
Like you were a psychotherapist
and a social worker.
Like you must have had some.
- Let me tell you something.
This is the thing it's
funny, Chris and I,
there's a guy here named
Chris that I'm dating.
- He might or might not be
sitting right behind you.
- Yeah, right behind me.
But we were just having
this conversation because
it's like sometimes I'm great
at helping every other person,
but you don't
understand how fast
that training goes out of
my mind when it comes to me.
- There it is.
- It just goes and anybody
who tells you like,
oh no, I've been trained.
And I know how to just do,
this is why doctors don't
perform on themselves
or why lawyers don't represent
themselves in court because
you sometimes don't
advocate for yourself
in the way you need to.
Yes, I have the knowledge.
I always look back and I'm like
if somebody would have
been in front of me,
I would have known exactly
what to say to them.
But when it's you,
I was like, I don't
know what to do here.
Like, oh, I'm screwed.
And so it, the knowledge
helps to some degree
once I got to a place
where I was kinda better
but for the most part,
it didn't help at all.
Because I was like, I was
in such a destructive path.
You know what I mean?
Like I just could not
get out of my own way.
I was so complacent
with hurting me,
and I don't mean
physically hurting me,
but I just realized
that every choice I made
was always going to
leave me to something
that put me in a situation
that I was uncomfortable with.
It put me in relationships
that I shouldn't have been in,
both friendships and intimate.
Every decision I was making
was about hurting me.
It was never conscious.
It was until I got a
little bit more sober
that I was able to evaluate that
to understand how the drugs and
alcohol were triggering that
what trauma I was experiencing.
It was a lot of why,
how that I went through.
- But at some point you must
have enlisted other people
to help guide you
through that process.
You weren't all doing this
in your head, were you?
- Kinda.
- Wow.
- I wish that I could,
because I have one sister,
her name is Camillia.
She and I are the closest
out of my sisters.
She was the only one
that was like, come here
but she didn't
have the language.
So she is a doctor of pharmacy.
And so she kinda understood
the drugs I was taking
and she would be like,
she would come to me.
And these are things that
I already kinda knew.
- Let me guess, like
cocaine, for sure.
- You loved cocaine.
Like, that would be
an understatement.
I'm not promoting this
to anybody watching.
- Ecstasy, MDMA.
- Ecstasy, coke, weed.
I never did like any heroin
crack or anything like that,
but it was a lot of like pills,
anything and then the liquor.
And then some nights it'd
be all of them because,
you'd get to the
party at 10 or 11
and you'd start
off with cocaine.
And then by one,
someone gives you a pill
and then by,
you're drinking through that
and then you have more coke
and then you get more pills.
And so she was
there to say, hey,
this is how your body chemistry
is reacting to these drugs
which was also kind
of nice for me to hear
because it was like,
okay, now I'm seeing
how it's like playing into
my depression, my anxiety.
And that also made
me realize, like,
I don't have to be depressed.
I don't have to be anxious.
I can relieve this substance
and then do more work
and relieve myself of
some of these feelings.
And so that was nice.
But she was the only one kinda--
- It's a interesting like level
of self-awareness and maturity
for somebody who's kind of
doing it internally, right?
Like not doing it in
a structured modality.
But I suppose,
God's like, dude, you're
like way off the reservation.
I'm gonna throw these
two kids at you.
- Exactly.
- And you need to pay attention.
Like if this doesn't
get your attention,
I don't know what to do.
- Well, that's what it was.
That's why I say the
kids saved me a lot.
Cause I was like,
if I can't pay
attention to myself,
then how am I gonna
pay attention to them?
You then just pass
on these trauma bonds
and these generational wounds.
And like, and instead
of like saying,
hey, before you have a kid,
you actually need to get a
license to heal yourself a bit.
You know what I mean?
And we're always a
work in progress,
but I just think it's
interesting that as adults,
we end up trying
to heal ourselves
while we're trying to
raise somebody else.
And then, they're now adults
and then now the
light bulb clicked
cause we're in our
thirties or forties
and we're like, oh crap.
I should have said this
to you when you were 10.
- I mean you know,
I've done so much work to grow
from the person that I was
into the person that I am now.
But it is remarkable.
The extent to which
I continue to repeat,
these habitual patterns
that are reflective
of things that my parents did.
I mean, I think so many of us,
we parent in opposition to
the way that we're parented.
Like we have some
wound, and we're like
I'm never gonna be
like that with my kid,
but we kind of go too far
in the other direction.
And I found myself
nonetheless despite adopting
that mentality perpetuating
something that I didn't like
about the way that
I was parented
because it's so
hardwired into me.
- [Karamo] So hardwired.
And the only way
that I can become,
that I'm made aware of it is
for example if Julie
reflects it back to me
or I do therapy
with a group of guys
and I'll share something
and they'll be like,
you're doing it again.
And I was like really, how am I?
I still can't see it.
And so these kids become
your gurus, right?
Because they
reflect back to you,
your wounding and your
pain and your patterns
and what it is that
you need to work on.
And that seems to be a reservoir
that you never
get to the bottom.
- Yeah, but if
you're a defensive
when they're mirroring it back,
then that's where you start
to pass on that trauma
and those wounds, because
then they start to pick it up.
Because once you're
defensive, they're like,
well, okay, dad does
wanna hear this.
Mom doesn't wanna hear this.
And then they start to pick up
the same behavior unconsciously.
I was talking...
I read some of the other day
which I thought was
just really great
that I wanna share is how,
those of us who were kids
and experienced trauma
or were teenagers
or young adults
and experienced
addiction or trauma,
you have learned how to
turn red flags green.
And I thought that was so great,
when you're in this space
of dealing with your trauma,
there's a red flag that pops up
when you're dealing with your
kids or dealing with life
where you know that
something is not right here
but you've turned that
red flag into a green flag
and giving yourself
permission to go.
And I think that if
we can start to learn
how to stop turning these
red flags into green flags
and teaching our kids how
to stop turning red flags
into green flags, it helps
them to find the courage
and the strength
to be able to say,
this behavior is not okay,
and I'm not gonna
go along with it.
I'm not gonna repeat it.
I'm not going to do
any of the things
that I've been taught to do,
because I can see the red flag.
And I think that visual of
like someone taking a red flag,
like, whew, whew, don't go here,
and being like, let
me paint this green.
I'm gonna go now, this is safe.
I think it's just such a great
visual for us to hold onto
as we're told.
As someone reflects back to
us, something that we're doing
where we can say, oh,
you reflected it back.
Great, let's all remember
this is a red flag.
None of us turn this
green, none of us.
You don't do it.
You don't do it
in a relationship.
And if you feel like
you're about to,
tell everyone in your circle,
what red flags is there it is.
Instead of like being
in a relationship
and then being like,
oh, I got to find out two years
later all the red flags when
be a little bit more honest
and vulnerable about it.
- Right, right.
Yeah, I mean the,
early days of any relationship,
is basically like a
grand play (indistinct).
- Pretend.
We are all pretending.
- We're modeling this
person we think that
they wanna be with and it
takes time before the cracks,
start to showing up.
- But could you imagine
if we got to a space where
we could just give those
red flags at the beginning.
And then how you can
start to heal yourself
and heal your relationships
so much quicker.
I just think that's
just a beautiful,
I mean, it's a little lofty
and like probably won't happen
but it's great
that I'm trying to,
I wanna learn how to
practice that more.
- Yeah, it's hard.
I'm such a pathological
people pleaser.
And it's like, I
mean even today,
it's like Karamo is
coming over here.
Like I want Karamo to like me,
you know what I mean?
Like, I am very
invested in that.
- So you're seventh
grader too, same thing.
- And I'm like, what
is that about, like.
So for me, it's still
this struggle of
trying to detach from
that aspect of my
personality which I accept,
but I'm always,
trying to overcome
on some level,
which is a close cousin to,
external validation and
the role that that plays.
It's like doing a podcast,
lots of people are
gonna listen to it.
I like the fact that, you
know what I mean, like
what aspect of that is fine
and what aspect of
that becomes unhealthy
and moves you
further apart from,
the truth that you're
trying to get at
in these conversations.
- Yeah, I think for me,
anytime I'm in those spaces
I got to think to myself,
am I doing this because
I know that I'm enough
or am I doing this because
I don't believe I'm enough.
And so that validation
is more important to me.
And I think just
practicing that awareness
that I am enough, I am okay.
Sort of is the fine line for me
of like remembering that,
yes, I might still have some
of that people pleasing in me
but the more you can
realize that, you're enough
so you don't have to
please other people.
You're enough, so even
if the validation comes
or doesn't come, it
doesn't matter matter
because you're enough.
And I think that's the practice.
That's the daily
reminder for yourself.
That's what you
have to hug on to,
and, you know, hook into.
Because when you
start to believe
that it seems very like woo hoo.
But it's at the truth
of the core of like,
I don't have to please
you because I'm enough.
I don't have,
like it's funny that
you would say like,
you're thinking like,
I might gonna like you,
when I'm the one who hit you up
and told you that I loved you.
You know what I mean?
But it's something that we
all play with in our minds.
And that narrative
got put in your mind
from someone in your childhood,
I don't wanna go
too deep with you,
but someone in your
past has said to you
and made you feel at some
point like you weren't enough.
And so then you start to feel
like, if I make these actions
and I do these things,
then I'll be worthy.
I'm good enough, I'm here.
- But then when you achieve
those things of course,
it's not enough.
And you have to chase
that like a dragon
for the rest of your life.
I mean, yeah, my upbringing
was all, not that,
it's like this weird thing
as I feel guilty
talking about this.
This is something I
explored with (indistinct).
He's like, your parents
did the best they could.
It's not about them
being good or bad.
But I think that there was a
conditional aspect to the love
in that we love you more
when you're excelling.
Like it was a very education
and achievement
oriented household.
And I got validation
out of playing that game
and succeeding at that game.
And that gets cemented
into my hard wiring that
today at 54, I'm still
playing out that pattern
in a very dysfunctional way.
- Yeah, I mean, what
you just said there
about the validation
in unhealthy way is
I think something
that most people
experience in their homes
and it goes back to
that conversation
we had earlier about
schools and sort of like,
the life skills we're not
receiving because you come home,
you get A, everyone's cheering,
they put it on fridge.
But when you say I found a
passion that makes me happy
that might not tell your
parents, you can make money.
They don't react the same way.
I also think about this
when I was raising my kids.
I had this philosophy
in my home that
if you told me the truth, you
would never get in trouble.
And I think we do a
disservice to children
in the way that we're
grooming them of when
you tell your kids to be honest.
But when they're honest,
they get punished.
Like what kind of
backwards way of training
and teaching someone.
It's similar to
like, you do good.
So now you get what you want...
you feel loved.
It's like a backwards way that
we really have to look at,
like the way that we're,
what we're teaching
unconsciously
and consciously to each other.
And so for, in my house,
if my kids got in trouble
and they told me the truth,
they didn't get punished.
They got rewarded with a hug,
with love, with more support,
with quality time, because,
and now we have a relationship.
My kids don't lie to me anymore
because now they don't fear
coming and tell me the truth.
And I broke this sort
of cycle in my household
and I'm not saying
there's other cycles
that are not still
getting perpetuated,
but in my household at least
where my kids don't feel like
they need to lie to get
that validation externally
because they know their
truth is good enough.
And you know, it's one of
those things where again
if someone would told you that,
hey, make an F, it doesn't
mean that you're a bad person.
I'm still gonna love you.
I'm still gonna celebrate
you as a human being.
What would have that
have done for you?
Like as a child, that would
have been amazing for you.
- Yeah.
But bridging that gap, like
overcoming that patterning
intellectually versus
emotionally is a journey, right.
Like you can say, look,
if you tell me the truth
I'm not gonna get mad at you.
And then you're like, you're mad
but you're trying not to act
as you know it's
the wrong thing.
That's very different from,
really coming with a
genuine, authentic,
sense of compassion
into that dynamic.
- Oh, completely.
- Well, that's where, like
I said before the rewarding,
understanding what the
reward is gonna be,
understanding what
your intention.
So the word reward for me is
also synonymous with intention.
So my intention here
is through my actions
to show you that I love you,
to give you this reward of like,
yes, I feel something inside
but externally you're going
to only be embraced by love.
You're only gonna be
embraced by positivity.
And it does take time.
It does take effort.
And this is where
training does help me.
Because as a parent, it
helped me to realize like
this is not gonna be healthy
if I do something opposite.
But, it does take time,
but everyone can get there.
We forget that we,
all it takes for you to
change your self-esteem
or the way that you're living
is to practice the
same thing daily.
That's all you have to do.
If you get up in the morning
time, you look in the mirror
or the first thing you do
is you downplay yourself
and say, oh, look
at how I look here.
I'll look at my nose, look
at my hair, it's going down.
You're practicing everyday
knocking your self-esteem down.
If you practicing in the
morning time coming in
and saying to your kids,
hey, are you ready
for school, whatever,
that first statement is,
you're practicing like
what is most important
and what is most valuable to you
versus coming in the room,
like I used to do
this with my kids
where I would come in the
room in the morning time
and before I would
wake them up and say,
we got to get to work.
I would give them a kiss
and just be like,
did you sleep well?
And I would sit with them
for like 10, 15 minutes
to understand that
my value is not
how fast you're gonna
get ready for school.
Not saying that's not a value,
but that's not the top
of my priority list.
And I think that we can
all learn how to practice,
what's our intention,
what's our values
more verses making
these (indistinct)
reaction of, I'm busy.
What happens when
you walk in the door,
do you go straight to the TV?
Do you go straight to your phone
or do you take a
moment to connect?
And if you practice
day by day doing that
then things get better.
- What's the current
blind spot with you?
Like what's the thing
that trips you up
and causes the struggle?
- With me.
- Yeah.
- Ooh.
I mean, right now it's,
I guess a lot of like,
cause I'm out of
one relationship
that I was in for 10 years and.
- And you were engaged
for a long time.
- Yeah, we were engaged
for a year and a half.
And so it's a lot of
like, understanding like
the things that I
didn't even know
were lurking I need
the surface that.
I guess I didn't heal from
or like were bothering me
and like how that can just
come out in a second now
and like being like,
oh, I need to really
go back through
and like really evaluate
what was happening
in this relationship.
And really being truthful
with myself about like things
and how they made me feel.
And so I think that's the thing
that's tripping me
up right now of like,
you think that you have a
handle on a relationship
but you realize that every
relationship is different
and every relationship needs
to be evaluated
differently and equally.
And I think that's
such an important thing
because I got out of a
relationship thinking
I'm fine, everything's good.
We ended on unhealthy place.
And then I was like,
oh no, I'm not fine, I'm not.
There was things that
were lurking underneath
that weren't the
big traumatic things
but they were still there,
and like finding that balance.
- And even under the
best circumstances,
when you've been with
somebody for a very long time
and then suddenly you're not.
If you think you're not,
dealing with some kind of,
latent emotional issue, you're
in complete denial, right.
- Yeah, completely, yeah.
And I say, this, it's
not regards to me
but I just wanna give
your listeners a thing.
It's okay to tell people
don't rush my healing.
I think some times we feel
as if like we're grieving
and we're going
through something,
whether it's like the
actual physical death
of someone actually the
end of a relationship,
or even just grieving
the financial security
you thought you were gonna
have, whatever you're grieving,
and especially in
this COVID world.
I think sometimes,
we put a timeline on
other people's grief
and other people's way
of healing and it's okay
to tell people don't
put a timeline on it.
Like, I don't like
or appreciate,
like when I hear friends saying,
oh my gosh, you're
still not over that guy.
It's like, just because
you've gotten over it,
doesn't mean you
can rush my healing.
A better response is, what are
ways that I can support you?
How can I get you
the help you can get
you need so that you can
feel like you can heal,
so that you can go through
this grieving process.
But I think as a culture,
we rush people's
breathing too much.
And I just wanna tell
people that it's okay
to tell someone, you don't
rush my process of healing.
- Yeah, that's beautiful.
I think that's sure important.
I think it's equally
applicable to,
the people in your lives that
you create expectations around
where they should be
with where you're at.
Like whether it's your dad,
and how he feels about how
you're living your life.
- Oh my gosh.
- We all hear those
stories of the newly sober
(indistinct) 30
days and he's angry
that no one's embracing him
back into their lives after
he's torched everyone for years.
That's a different kind of
healing and you gotta be patient
with the people that you love
and that are in your circle.
Allow them to have their
own their own journey
with whatever it is
that they're undergoing.
- Yeah, you let them
have their journey.
I think, you know,
that's some of the things
like when I tell people,
there's two things I
wanna say that because
the first is you got
to let other people
have that healing, that journey.
And I think it's,
that's why I say
it's so important for
people to know that
and to understand that
it's a dual thing,
it's both sides.
Because I always tell people,
when I let people into my
life regarding my sexuality
I don't use the term coming out,
I think it give the
power to the person.
- I think you said that right.
Explain that a little bit.
- Well, when you say coming out,
it gives the power
to the other person
to accept or deny you.
And the process that I
actually did was let people in.
And when you let someone in,
you have the power to
deny or love yourself,
accept or deny yourself.
And so it has nothing
to do with you.
It's about I'm
letting you in and
if you don't wanna
be here with me,
then that's fine
because I still love me.
So if you've done
the work on yourself.
I always think about it as,
your body's a temple.
So if your letting someone
into your sexuality
into some part of your life,
if you open that front
door and you say,
come on in and they
say, I don't want to.
If you've done the
work on your home,
you close that door and
you walk in your own home
and feel comfortable
and you feel loved.
And so I think it gives
the person back the power
and the understanding to,
that it's not about them
accepting, denying you.
It's about you
loving yourself more.
And also this whole
antiquated idea
of like coming out the closet.
I don't know where
hell this closet is.
And if there is a
closet, I wanna find it.
There's gotta be a pot of gold.
And if all the BS
I've been through,
and I wanna burn
down this closet
so nobody else has
to come out of it.
Like, it's all about
letting people in.
But, when I was letting
people and I would say,
I understand that in my
mind, I had been dealing
with an understanding and
loving my sexuality and who I am
for five years before
I let anyone know.
So when I let
certain people know,
I realized they had to
grieve an entire identity
that they have constructed
in there minds.
And I'm not saying that
it's my fault or that
they have any blame
or I have any blame.
But you have to understand that
if this is what I've
known about you,
and one day you say,
nope, erase that
this is something different.
Yes, you want them
to get to a point
where they can accept you
and love you for who you are,
but they have to have
their time to grieve.
And so I think you have to
give people their time to heal.
So like when I worked
in social services
and I worked with kids, I
would say understand that
it took you five
years in your mind
and talking to other little
friends to get to where you are.
It might take your
mom or your sister,
your cousin, five years too.
We all would love the beautiful
stories that we see on TV
where people just are like,
I accept you and I love you
right here off the spot.
But most of the time
when that happens
it's because that person
had some type of inclination
and they were already doing
the healing on their own
or they had a
friend in their past
that they were
healing on their own
and healing their biases
and everything else.
But you have to take that time
to let other people
heal as well.
And so it's okay
for a parent to say,
I need a little time to
grieve and to heal myself.
It doesn't mean
I don't love you.
I love you.
I need the time to
process and heal.
But secondly, on
what you were saying,
when you're talking about
the sobriety and like the guy
who was like 30 (indistinct).
I think there's something
else that we do.
And this is something
I say all the time
which is compression
is the thief of joy.
When you compare yourself
and your experiences
to other people, you're
still your own joy.
And I think as a culture
we do that way too often.
We look at people on Instagram
and instead of thinking about
what we have in our own
lives and how beautiful
the small and big
things that we have,
we end up comparing
our bodies, our minds,
our inner circles,
little trinkets that you have
to what other people have.
And you have to stop doing that.
If you have 30 days,
don't compare yourself
to what other people are,
what they're not doing.
They're not accepting you.
Again, they're on their
journey of healing.
But just don't compare
yourself to anything else.
Just know it will
happen in your own time.
Don't steal your own joy
focusing on something else.
- You can also steal that
joy by comparing yourself to
an idealized version of yourself
or past version of yourself.
So you don't actually even
need that other person.
- You don't need it.
You can just looking
at your own--
- I do, it's all in my head.
- Oh my gosh.
That's such a
great point because
I have a girlfriend
who right now is
on a physical
health journey where
her body has changed
after children.
And she constantly it's like,
oh, my old body,
I want that body.
And I'm like, just the biology,
none of our bodies
will ever be the same
as they were from day one.
And so you have to
be okay and except
that your body where
it is now is enough.
And if you wanna work
out to be healthier,
but you have to stop comparing
yourself to that old body,
like you said because
you're now stealing the joy
of being like, there's
something beautiful
about whatever
body you're in now.
There's something great about it
and find what that is.
Again, going back to
practicing in the mirror,
what is one thing on this
new body that you can love
about yourself versus comparing
yourself to an old body.
Stop stealing your own joy by
comparing yourself to others
or your old version of yourself,
I think it's so critical.
I'm glad you had that piece.
- In addition to
that more broadly,
like outside of the context of,
sharing some aspect of who
you are and being attached
to how people are
going to receive that,
the growth is in
understanding that
how people feel about you on
some fundamental level really
isn't your business.
- At all.
- And even if it was, you're
unable to control that.
- [Karamo] Completely.
- And the extent to which
human beings try to do that
I think is really the engine
of so much unhappiness.
Like we're all trying to
control our environments,
position ourselves to be
received in a certain way.
And it's all this delusional
attempt to manipulate the world
so that it,
appears as we would
like it to be.
And the freedom only
comes in the surrender
to the idea that that is
beyond our ability to control
and to make peace with that,
to accept the fact that
that's them, I'm me.
I'm only in charge of myself,
how I feel about myself,
my actions, my
reactions, my thoughts.
- How did you go to that place
where you have that freedom?
- I'm still working on it.
(Karamo laughs)
You know what I mean.
I mean, you know,
I got sober in 98
and spent a long time
in a treatment center and,
very much steeped in the
recovery community here in LA.
And I do therapy and
I have my wife who is,
been instrumental in helping
guide me through a lot of--
- She's pretty pretty
amazing, we met briefly.
- Identifying my
shortcomings and,
just being, I don't mean
that in a negative way.
I mean that in a way of being
able to see what I can't see
and being able to communicate,
hey, you might
wanna look at this,
like, you're doing this thing,
like maybe think about that
or is there a better
way to do that.
- Completely.
- But you know, I'm the
furthest from perfect.
And it's a strange situation,
like in hosting this podcast
and people say like,
how do you do this?
How do you that?
I'm like, dude,
like, I'm trying to,
why do you think I'm doing this?
I'm trying to figure this out.
- We figure this out together.
- Like I don't stand on any
kind of pedestal in terms of,
knowing answers that
other people don't.
Like I grapple with this stuff
mightily every single day.
- Yeah, I gotta tell
you, I'm the same way.
I'm the same way,
like I shared with you earlier,
when it comes to
myself, sometimes I,
of course I'm able to
especially identify,
someone's trauma or
triggers and help them
to kind of navigate
through that.
But, you know,
I'm still learning
constantly myself,
we're all human beings.
And I think that
freedom of letting go
is something that
we all strive to.
And I feel like I get
closer on some days
and other days I'm like,
damn, I missed the boat today.
I just really missed it.
But it's also, giving myself,
you know, forgiving myself.
I'm big on that.
Like I once a day will say
to myself, I forgive you.
I literally would do
it in the morning,
sometimes I'll do
it in the night.
I'll just look at myself in
the mirror and I'd be like,
I forgive you.
And it's my way of saying, like,
you're human.
You made that mistake today,
but what are you
gonna do tomorrow?
How are you gonna make a
better choice tomorrow.
And I think sometimes
people are scared to make
the better choice
tomorrow because
they hadn't forgiven themselves
for what they did yesterday.
And, you know,
when you can let go of your
ego and say I forgive myself,
now let me go and see if I can,
rebuild the bridge that I,
broke with someone else by,
acknowledging with through
not being defensive,
what I've done.
I tried to start
conversations really,
quickly with like,
listen, I know what I did.
I mean, let me be very clear.
Like we don't have to spend
two hours of like pretending.
I know what I did,
and I'm sorry.
And I think forgiving
myself first of the actions
and then saying,
will you forgive me
and allowing someone to be
on their journey of saying,
yes or no, I might
need some time is okay.
And I think that's how I
get to that freedom as well.
- Yeah, by doing
your own inventory
and then leading with honesty,
integrity and vulnerability.
Like when you initiate those
challenging conversations
from a perspective of,
let me just own up front
like my side of this
equation that went sideways
you're in a much better
situation in terms
of being able to navigate
to a healthy place.
- And also take some defense.
I'm telling anybody who's
listening, just should try it.
Like if you're in a
situation with somebody,
we all know at our core
what role we played
for the most part and the demise
of relationships, intimate
or personal or friendships.
You know what you did,
you might not wanna acknowledge.
You might not wanna say it
out loud, you might not.
But you know.
I'm telling you next time
you're in a space with that
person, just acknowledge it.
Just say it, like
just go for it.
I'm telling you
it's going to create
a healthier relationship
like you can't even imagine.
Just being like, it's
just surrendering.
It's where like, I get it.
I did it, I'm sorry.
Like, I'm not gonna
defend it right now.
I did it,
and we can have a
conversation later about
why I might have done it
but I'm not gonna defend it.
I just did it, sorry.
- That's the mistake I
think a lot of people make.
Like, they'll do that but then
there's always a but or...
- Don't do the but.
Just leave the buts out.
- Get rid of the but.
Yeah, like let it
land without that
is always much better.
Well, I think like
your true gift is that
you carry this vibration and
you do it in a masculine body
and you enter into
these scenarios
with these various
individuals on the TV show,
you help them see
their way through
their own kind of mental
and emotional hurdles.
But in a broader sense,
you're giving men
permission to grapple with
and confront their emotions
in a culture in which,
we've come a long way,
but let's face it.
Like there's still
a long way to go
in terms of getting the average
dude to think about things
like vulnerability and
inventory and loving oneself
and even talking
about their fears.
- Yeah.
I don't know where in our
culture, we went wrong.
I don't know where,
I don't know when.
But like this idea that
men aren't vulnerable
that they don't hurt,
that they don't have.
Well, actually I do have an
idea of where this shit started.
Like for me, I believe,
I believe there is a God
but I think it's narrow-minded
to believe that God is a man.
When we see everything on
this earth, it's created
and formed by women.
I'm like now he's,
a guy all of a sudden did this.
And so, I revere women because
the people who are usually
my spiritual guys, my mentors
have always been women.
So I think that women are
the most powerful beings
on this face of this earth.
And I think that when we sort
of put women into a category
because we were intimidated or
afraid of their awesome power
is when men start to feel
this sort of like need to say,
well, okay, I'm stronger
now because I'm limiting you
and I'm gonna have this
power and say that look
like I'm strong, but because
of your wholeness, you cry.
I don't cry.
I've diminished that.
And I think we did
it to ourselves.
And then I think through time,
it got perpetuated through
movies, stereotypes,
and then even some women
started subscribe to it.
Like my man is not strong
if he shows emotion
or something of that nature.
But I think what's happening
now is we're seeing that shift
because of the shift of our
culture with mental health
this period of like,
we can't keep on going
and ignoring this.
We saw what happened
to our grandparents
and our great-grandparents.
And we're seeing what happens
when generations completely
ignore their mental health
and only focused on
their physical health.
And I think men are
starting to wake up to, like
I have to be better for myself.
I have to be better for
the women in my lives.
I had to be better for my kids.
I have to be better
and they wanna be better.
And that's the thing that I
always tell people on Queer
and they're like,
what's the magic touch.
Anybody can talk
about your trauma.
The reason that these men
have these emotional moments
with me is because I'm giving
them permission to know that
their masculinity is not
invalidated by emotion.
And I think it's so important
for men just to know that
like, whatever you've
constructed of masculinity
in your mind is
not gonna be broken
just because you say
to someone I'm scared,
because you say to
someone like I'm confused,
it actually makes
you stronger, sexier.
It makes you all these things
that you actually
thinking you're not.
Like I've never ran into
a woman who was like
on dating this guy and
he was honest with me
and it turned me off.
That's not a thing guys.
Like, you know what I mean?
Or like, oh my gosh,
we had a conversation
and he let me in,
now I'm turned off.
That's literally the exact
opposite that men should learn.
And I think if we could
start telling them that,
it even just gives them more
permission just to be open
and honest about who they
are and what they're feeling.
- Yeah, I think the real
emotional heart of the show
is born out of
those moments where,
you and your colleagues
are are showing,
this person a
level of compassion
that they've never experienced
in their life before.
And when you sit down
and give them permission
to be vulnerable
or to ask them questions
that nobody has ever asked
them before, like that's where,
you're like, and you could
see the look on their face
and the way that their
bodies feel is like,
this is new to this.
Like no one has ever shown
that kind of unconditional love
and support for this person
in their entire life.
- Yeah.
And you know,
for me it's so special
because I remember the day,
I was probably like in,
I was probably in ninth grade,
the minute that I realized
that I needed to start
giving compassion to myself
and to others in that way.
And so it's interesting and
amazing that now I have a career
where I do it publicly
and on television.
But there's a story I wanna
share with you really quickly
that I used to play
football in high school.
And I remember we
would play football
and while we were practicing
the girls would be doing their,
running around the track.
And I remember I got tackled
cause I was a wide receiver
and my leg was busted up.
I mean, like I was screwed up
and all I remember is my
coach screaming at me,
Brown, get up,
Brown, run it all, Brown.
And I'm sitting
here and I'm crying.
He was like, Brown,
suck it up, go.
Brown, get up.
And I'm like in pain.
And then I remember this girl
and I'm not gonna say her name
cause I'm still
friends with her but
she was running a hurdle and
she tripped on the hurdle
and she had the tiniest
scratch on her knee.
And that same coach that was
just telling me to run off
my then, I found
out my broken leg
was like ran to her
with everyone else.
And was like, oh my
gosh, what is wrong?
What is going on?
Are you okay?
Okay, are you fine?
And that was the day
I was like, F this.
If you don't wanna give
me compassionate love,
I got to give it to myself.
And then I'm going to then
try to give to other people.
And literally I quit and
became a peer counselor.
I'm not even joking.
His reaction set me on
a whole new path of like
I'm now going to be a peer
counselor for other kids here.
Also, it got me out of like,
second and fifth period
because I was able to.
So there was a little another
little motivation there.
But I was like, if
you're gonna tell me
that I have to endure pain
without any love or support,
then I'm gonna make sure that
other people you tell that too
can leave you and
come to me and,
get the love and support
you're not giving them.
And I literally started
doing that then,
did it through college.
And it's where I am now,
ironically my career.
But I can pinpoint that moment
of him screaming at me Brown
and this girl being
on the, you know.
- Right, amazing, wow.
It's gotta be hard to
practice that, like in
quote unquote, all
your affairs, like,
especially now where culture
just feels so fractured
and I'm thinking back on
the particular episode
of you guys with the cop,
which was, was that in.
That was in the South
somewhere, I can't--
- Yeah, we were in
Atlanta for that and,
yeah, that was,
a big one there.
- We watched that.
I think when we
watched that episode
it was like right in the
vortex of George Floyd.
So yeah, it was
like the timing of,
watching that show, which was
obviously taped much earlier.
It was so like challenging
to get on board with the idea
that you guys are
gonna help this guy
after you get pulled over
and that little stunt.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was a difficult moment
because we all felt
really triggered,
especially myself,
Tan and Jonathan
who had experienced police
brutality because of,
for Tan, I, our
race or nationality.
And for Jonathan,
because of the fact that,
being non binary,
people would harass him
for being a human
being who has a beard
but also is in a skirt.
And we understood like
real police brutality.
We understood that
like there were police
that are not here to
protect and serve you.
There are some that are bad.
And it, you know
in that moment it was
like, okay, this is hard.
But I think one of
my greatest gifts
and I was talking
about this with Chris
when I mentioned earlier
the other day is I was like
I don't mind going to
spaces where people
who feel differently than me
and trying to make a bridge.
And so I saw that as an
opportunity with this cop
of being like, hey
this is a moment for us
to see each other.
And it doesn't mean that it's
gonna change how you police.
It doesn't mean it's gonna
change how your friends police,
but hopefully if I tell
you that my son at 16,
didn't wanna get his license,
something that we all wanna do.
If I tell you this, maybe
I can get to your heart.
And maybe I can, instead of
trying to change your mind,
I can change your heart.
And then the next kid you
see that may look like my son
you'll stop and think,
is this Karamo's son
before you make your choice.
And, it was powerful.
Even in the episode
you could see he's
physically bawling at the end
cause he's like, our car ride
just meant the most to him
because he was met with
empathy and saying like,
hey, were at the end of the
day we want the same things.
We've just had these
experiences that put us
on a different path.
But if you go back
to your heart,
you go back to your emotions,
you can get back on
that path of love and,
all those things.
And so,
it's really nice.
- I mean, it's so powerful.
And I look at that as
almost like a template or,
an instruction manual
for how to interface
with the world right now.
We're on the back end of like
this unbelievably
divisive election,
I don't know in my lifetime,
a period in which
we were so divided.
This unbelievable breakdown
in our ability to communicate
in a healthy way and
identify common ground,
when in truth we
share so much more
than that which divides us.
And I spent a lot of
time thinking about,
as a public facing person,
like, how do I talk about this?
How do I interface with
people who disagree with me?
And I'm very much somebody
who doesn't court controversy,
I wanna build bridges.
But I also feel
there are moments
where it's important to
speak your truth even though,
you know you're
gonna get attacked
or whatever's gonna
happen with that.
And everything is on such
a tight trigger right now.
It's like, everybody's
ready to snap.
And I feel like the only
way forward for our culture
if we wanna have
a shot at being,
the United States of America,
is figuring out how to build
those individual bridges
in our personal lives.
How do we communicate?
Like, okay, Thanksgiving
just happen.
We're coming up on,
the bigger holidays.
Like how do you
interact with people
who see the world
differently from you?
How can you find
that common ground?
And how can,
we really embrace the
things that we share
and transcend all
of the divisiveness
that's really dragging us down
and making us anxious
and depressed.
And it's really,
it's deeply concerning
to me when I look at
what's happening out there.
- Well, the first thing
I say to people is that
we need to get, as a society,
we need to get rid
of cancel culture
and switch it with
council culture.
I think that we have
gotten to a place where,
it's easy to jump on a
bandwagon, council someone.
But then what we forget is
that once you've council them
all they do is go, they get
further pushed into a group
of people who believe and
feel the same way they feel.
It's very rare as we've
seen in these past couple
of years where cancel
culture, they're popular.
It's very rare where someone
who's been canceled
actually changes
either privately or publicly.
All do is they revert
back to a group
that believes what they believe.
And I think that's
part of the problem.
Instead of canceling them,
we should be giving these
people opportunities
to sit down and be
counseled by someone.
And I think council culture
is a very healthier way
of saying your
actions were wrong.
Your actions were wrong
because this is how it made
this group of people feel.
Now, let's talk about why
did you feel it was okay
to hurt this group of people?
Why did you feel it was
okay to hurt this person?
What in your own past led you
to think that this was okay?
What part of your power access
makes you think that this is
the appropriate way to react?
Giving people
opportunities to grow
and learn instead
of canceling them
is I think so important.
But to do that, you have
to have a group of people
who understand the importance
of empathetic listening.
So when I go into
situations with people
who are different than me,
the first thing I think about
is some of my grandma used
to say, immigrants
used to say which is
you have two of these,
you have one of these.
Two ears, one mouth.
So you're supposed to be
doing one double time and
one a little less.
And I think about
that all the time.
And so when I go into something,
instead of me jumping into
a conversation and like, just
trying to defend my point
or like tell you why
you're wrong or whatever
because I now know as an adult,
that's gonna only
shut them down.
I go into and I say, hey,
let's start the premise
with your actions hurt
this person, me, someone else.
I wanna hear why you
made that action.
And then I don't
go into anything.
And this is key.
I'm now listening.
But within the listening
something else that
I think people do
is they then start to
conjure up ways to defend
a point of view that
they don't even know yet.
So you assume the other
person is gonna say something.
So you already have your,
what you're gonna say back.
It happens in
couples all the time.
I see it all the time.
Every time I see a
breakdown in a couple
it's because they're already
ready, they're defensive.
It's like, I know what
I'm gonna say to you
to get you back to say it back.
And we have to release that.
So if I'm gonna listen to you,
I'm gonna listen to you without
having a rebuttal already.
And I think that's so key.
So instead of canceling
you, I'm gonna counsel you
by listening and not
having a rebuttal.
And I think you have to
then also understand if
is this person in a space
to actually receive this?
Because I think sometimes
we get blue in the face.
We're trying to talk to
people who are just not ready.
They're just not ready.
And also they're not ready
because they've been triggered
by the last 10 peoples
who try to talk to them,
who didn't do it properly,
who all told they were wrong.
And so you have to say,
well, am I really in a
space to wanna build trust
and build a bigger connection?
Like in my career so far, I've
been canceled probably a lot
but I get counseled often
because I do believe.
Yeah, I get counseled
all the time.
I'll give you some
examples of recent.
I get canceled
because people say,
why would you talk
to this person?
Why would you interact
with this person?
But it goes to what we
talked about at the beginning
of this interview is,
I didn't have the luxury being
black gay immigrant parents
to not try to reach out to those
who were different from me.
I didn't have that luxury know.
I never had that luxury.
The only way I've succeeded
and find a healthy
boundary is by saying,
I got to meet you
where you're at
because that person was
never gonna meet me.
And so it's always
been my burden
but always has been
my greatest triumph
of being able to say, I know I
can meet you where you're at.
And I think,
like I got canceled last year
because I called Sean Spicer,
Trump's former press
secretary, a nice guy,
and then tried to
engage with him.
- All right, cause you guys
did Dancing with the Stars.
- Did Dancing with the
Stars together and he,
I don't agree with
any of his politics
but I was like, you know what?
If there's a way that I
can maybe help this man
to see how his actions
are effecting people,
I love and affecting my life.
Maybe he will,
his heart will
change just enough
that when he's
around some people
who would never be around me,
he can like, it will start to
come out of him unconsciously,
where he's starting
to talk like Karamo.
He doesn't even realize it
because it's like
I've hit his heart.
And people were like, I can't
believe you said he was nice.
And I was like, I didn't
say his politics were nice.
I said, him as a human being,
I could see him as a human.
I could see his fears.
I could see his pain.
I could see the manipulation.
I could see everything in him.
And I could remove that and say,
well, now let me try to
help you to even be better.
I went visited--
- You have to be able
to be able to do that.
If the solution is you just
never have anything to do
with that person because
they don't see the world
the way that you
do, we're doomed
- We're doomed.
And that's where we
are as a culture.
We are, and that's why I say,
get rid of cancel culture,
put it with council culture,
be more empathetic at listening.
Really be there and not
to like have a rebuttal
and just really understand
if the person is ready.
And I think then we'll
start to get to a place
where more people are
open, honest, vulnerable
and finding common ground.
Because I wanna end on this.
If the aliens came down tomorrow
not saying I believe in aliens,
but if the aliens came down
tomorrow, I promise you
none of us are gonna
be like you're black,
you're white, you're
gay, you're straight.
We're gonna be like, oh, shit.
It's us against these aliens
who are about to eat us all.
And so, not calling the aliens,
if there are like, they're mean,
but I'm just saying like
we have to come back to
a place like right now
we've made each other the enemy.
And like, at the end of the day,
we're all trying to
survive on this big planet
where things are alive and
can kill us all at any moment.
So let's all just come
together and realize that.
- Yeah, here's the
pessimistic note though.
You would think replace
aliens with pandemic.
Like if a pandemic happened,
we would all have to unite
and collectively figure out
how to solve this problem.
And we all know what
we're seeing right now
which is an exacerbation of
this divide in a way that
I don't know if any of
us could have predicted.
But I think your
point is well taken.
And it really is--
- But even when this
pandemic, I'll say this,
I think the problem was
not just the (indistinct).
- Politicized, I can't.
- Politicization.
- You cancel.
- Exactly, cancel.
It's not just because
they politicize that,
with the mask and
everything else.
I think it's also because again,
when you don't touch
someone's emotions
then their mind
will never change.
And so I don't want anyone
else to die from this pandemic.
So let me be very clear.
But I think the fact
that the number of deaths
weren't affecting so
many people's homes,
that they really,
a lot of people weren't
seeing their grandmas pass.
People were getting,
recovering really quickly.
If this pandemic would
have really unfortunately
taken more lives.
And I'm not saying
that the lives
that were taken
were undervalued but
I think then we would have
seen the common enemy,
and it didn't matter how
they try to politicize it.
It would've been like,
no, we're all in this.
And I think that's
what we went wrong
when we were fighting
people with mask.
I never tried to have like
the mask conversation early on
because I was like,
I'm not gonna get you.
If you've already been told
them, (indistinct) stupid,
your mind is set.
But if I can show you how
my sister or my cousin
or my aunt is sick right now
and really get to you one-on-one
not just on a Facebook
feed, just one-on-one,
talk to somebody, that's
where it got better.
And I spent a lot of time in
the early days of pandemic
and doing Zoom calls
with people who did not,
all my podcasts, which I
can never use any of it
because when my
podcast comes back out,
like it's gonna be gone.
But it was like.
- Everything changes.
- You see differently,
can I just talk to you?
And through that conversation,
I would say about eight out of
10 will change their hearts.
And I saw it physically
on their Instagram
where they will all
of a sudden be like,
damn, I didn't know that this
was really affecting someone.
So that's to play
on your pessimists.
- Well, to be sure things like
podcasts are super important
because you've got to be
able to create the space
and the bandwidth and
allow for the nuance
and the back and forth.
Like this is not
happening on Twitter.
And if we want a
shot at bridging this
divide, we've gotta,
divorce ourselves a little
bit from those platforms
and invest a little bit more
on that one-on-one amen.
- Amen.
And invest in the one-on-one.
- We'll round this
out in a minute,
but I can't let you go without
asking you one more thing,
which is to...
- No, you don't need
to be on Queer Eye.
(indistinct), right now
that you do not need to be,
you're literally the after photo
of what we do on Queer Eye.
I'm just gonna let you
know that right now,
you're not coming on the show.
- Oh, my goal is achieved.
Thank you.
I'm interested in your thoughts
on your experience of
working with so many people,
what are the common things
that tend to trip people up
and kind of show
up his blind spots?
Like, what's the thing that
when you look around you see
that guy just knew
this one thing,
like he could transform himself
or herself.
- Communication.
Communication, it's funny as
a species who uses language
whether it's through your
voice, through sign language
to interact with others, we are
such horrible communicators.
We don't communicate to
ourselves what we're feeling.
others what we're feeling,
our communication is so broken.
We get into conversations
and we stop ourselves.
Like we talked about
earlier in the conversation
where you just,
you close off your voice.
You stop speaking,
you stop sharing.
And I think that's the thing
that I would just
want most people,
every person I come across with.
I'm like, well,
why didn't you ever tell
anybody this was happening?
Why didn't you ever admit
to yourself that
this was going on?
Why didn't you ever share?
And it's like, I didn't know
how to communicate this.
- And asking for help
is weakness or scary.
- Asking for help is weakness.
But again, asking for help
as a form of communication.
And so it all kinda for me,
goes back to communication.
And I think if we
could really give,
not to go back, but if we
instead in school taught people
who were never gonna use,
trigonometry ever
again in their lives
a class that would teach
them how to communicate.
I loved English and I
loved reading books.
It was one of my
favorite subjects,
but no one in that class taught
me how to truly communicate
what's going on.
That's not a skill
we're really learning.
You learn it from the
streets, your home.
And that's where
we get caught up.
I see it on Queer all the time.
I literally like,
why didn't you communicate
this to anybody?
Why didn't you communicate
this to yourself?
Why didn't you ask for help?
Why what was going on?
And that fear
around communication
is the biggest issue
that stops us all.
- Yeah, and then the
release that you see
when they finally
are going to do it,
it's like they suddenly
lose 20 pounds.
- Completely.
So I would encourage
people in your friendships,
in your relationships,
as parents, highlight
communication more,
encourage your kids, encourage
your friends to talk more,
be patient with them
as they're talking,
which I think is so important.
Like, people don't always,
not all of us or
(indistinct) we can just,
share a speech
and say something.
Sometimes things come out
confusing, it comes out wrong.
This is something that I've
been dealing with right now,
with someone of like
being patient with them
and understanding like your
intention is not to hurt me.
You're just learning how to
communicate in a new way.
And I think it's so
important because
when you can let
someone communicate,
when we can
communicate together,
when you communicate to yourself
honestly, world opened up.
- That's a beautiful
way to end it my friend.
You're beautiful man, Karamo.
You're an inspiration.
I wish you only well.
- So are you my friend,
I'm so glade to be here.
As a fan of your show,
I'm so happy to on it.
- The honor is all mine.
When is the show resume?
Is it you guys have a production
schedule, what's going on?
- No, they haven't told
us probably February
because we're,
our show is all about
connection, hugging.
The minute that goes
out for the show,
you've missed it.
- You can't,
what are you gonna do?
- Yeah, you can't.
- There is no show.
- There's no show.
We can't be six feet apart.
You know what I mean.
So we're trying to
figure that out now.
And so for me, I don't get
political but I'm very thankful
that we have a president now
who's gonna take the
pandemic serious.
And I'm also,
I wanna highlight the fact
which I think has gotten
washed under too much.
The fact that we have our
first female vice president,
who I just, I'm so glad
that we now have a woman
in that office.
And I hope that,
and I know that she
will not be the last
and I can't wait for the
day that both the president
vice president and speaker
of the house are all women.
And, I promise you, our
country is gonna be great.
We already know what
happens when men run it.
It's shitty.
We've seen it.
I'm just being real with you.
Wars, everything.
We started them.
We did all this shit, famine,
all the we talking about.
We did it.
Women didn't do it, we did it.
So let's put them in charge
and this is the first step.
And I feel very optimistic.
- Beautiful.
Come back and talk
to me again sometime.
- Anytime, you tell
me, we're neighbors.
- (indistinct) peace, bless.
(upbeat music)